so I've been a magazine photographer for
just under 30 years I started as
photojournalist in California and I grew
up in Southern California and in some
way I kind of feel that my dad who is
not a photographer who was a welder his
photograph of the Apollo 11 launch may
very well have ignited my lifelong
passion for photography many people feel
that when they experience the they
experience a moment firsthand there's a
real clear anchor to that point in time
and we have this paradigm of that
experience that lives with us after that
launch took place for the next several
days humankind would be united as a
species and my dad realized that this
was a significant moment so much so that
he got our camera off the shelf family
camera dusted it off and he had it at
the ready to take a picture of the
launch off the TV screen this thing
starts to lift off the pad and I
remember the distinct pop of the
flashbulb my dad took that picture and
it's it's really cemented in my memory
sent the film to the pharmacy the local
pharmacy film came back and we had this
perfect photograph of our TV set the
flash bulb had obviously washed out the
image on the screen
hence my dad's career as a welder really
burdened after that and I was incredibly
disappointed I remember I'm so
disappointed but now to me it's almost
it's like almost a religious relic to me
like it takes me there Apollo 15 1971
Dave Scott it was a mission commander
this is the first mission that NASA
specifically trained the astronauts to
be geologists and observers and really
used their learned expertise to try to
communicate back to the scientists on
the ground what they were seeing NASA in
its infinite wisdom and an incredible
precaution decided they wanted to land
at a region called Mariusz Hills which
is really similar in terrain to the
Apollo 11 12 and 14 landing sites
basically a really safe flat surface
kind of a lunar desert on the other hand
the geologist wanted to land at a
location called Hadley Hadley
hadley real it's a very very rugged
region at the base of the Apennine
mountains what you see here they're
sometimes referred to as the lunar
himalayas there are massive mountains
and of course the geologists on earth
they they want to know what's there
what's there they pushed for the
Apennines nasa push for marius
there was stalemate that was reached and
there's kind of a legendary meeting that
took place where it's like you know
we're sequestering ourselves into this
room until we decide where we're gonna
land everybody wait in stalemate right
at the end of the meeting Dave Scott
mission commander gave his opinion on it
they've said that Landing and Hadley
will be trickier but I'm confident that
we can land at either site from what
I've learned in the field the Hadley
oppening site with its complex variety
of features both impact and volcanic is
the best choice for putting together a
picture of how the moon came to be it
will be a little riskier but the
Apennines have something else they have
grandeur and I believe there's something
to be said for exploring in beautiful
places it's good for the spirit you know
I want to start crying hold on sir I
like American Idol auditions I'm like on
the floor and fetal position the thing I
find beautiful about that is you know
leading up until that point astronauts
were really test pilots they were
fighter pilots they were engineers they
were button pushers they were working
the problem regardless of what was going
on and NASA started to try to push the
astronauts into sort of a more poetic
phase of exploration they wanted the
kind of spirit of the mission to come
out they they really really pushed for
that there Alan bean was sketching on
the moon you know there was a great
quote by Pete Conrad where where Albion
said look up look at the earth look you
know it's an earth rise look at the
earth rise and Pete Conrad said who was
the consummate engineer test pilot
fighter pilot said I seen one earth you
seen them all so we've got that was
Apollo 12 and by 15 we had Dave Scott
talking about grandeur and spirit which
I always found was really beautiful so
in 1972
Gene Cernan and Harrison Schmitt were on
the lunar surface and NASA sent them a
radio communication the Congress had
just approved funding for the
construction of the next generation of
space exploration vehicle it's called
the space transportation system but it
quickly became known as the space
shuttle early on it became apparent that
the model had its limitations it had
flaws it would ultimately be wrought
with budget overages you know in its
30-year career endure tragedies and
triumphs and so in 2011 NASA announced
that there are three orbiters left we
have missions for all three of those
each one of them gets a last launch and
it's over growing up in that space
period and that space age and space race
you know everything was space you know
tange I remember loving tang and all the
things that came out of the space
program sideways so when they made this
announcement I felt initially I felt
this jab and I thought my god I'd been
to a couple launches you know what it
takes the violence that it takes to sort
of like escape you know the earth is
it's a really profound thing so I got
this idea my wife actually had the idea
I think but I'm gonna claim it for now
because she's not miked yeah that I
would go and I would document the last
three launches the last three orbiters
so I went about designing a way to shoot
the launches there's so much
infrastructure involved in just getting
this thing to work I wanted to
photograph the result of this incredible
effort so he decided to photograph the
infrastructure the buildings the
hardware the vessel they're beautiful to
look at they're battle-scarred they're
patched yeah I went under one of the
shuttles and the thing had patches
everywhere all over it you know you
could just tell it had just been through
hell really on re-entry you know went in
the vehicles if there was a sacredness
to the inside of the vehicles all the
shuttle interiors and the ancillary
stuff in the processing and the
spacesuit processing stuff all of the
engine processing fascinating I mean
these are industries in and of
themselves these are space M&Ms which I
actually really liked it's the old
Mission Control from the Apollo era
which actually up until 96 worked on the
shuttle program so this all came
together in
that I released in 2012 called last
launches my third book and it just is a
chronicle of this of this program the
only person that appears in the book is
this man walking down the ramp away from
pad 39a which amazingly is the same pad
that the Apollo 11 launch took place so
photographing the launches themselves
this is a logistics thing like how do
you do this you know the shuttles
basically in two minutes is completely
out of sight and I want to compress that
into images and I want to I want to be
able to expand that time so this this is
a shuttle actually on the pad that's
similar this this black part right here
is the flame trench so you see these
huge solid rocket boosters here when the
they ignite fire comes down through the
pad into the flame trench and it goes
through this big port and there are
these nozzles which is really
interesting these are all water nozzles
and just prior to the engine start they
dropped millions of gallons of water
down into the flame trench because the
sound pressure wave from the shuttle
engines igniting and the vibration would
just rattle the thing apart so they use
the water for sound suppression and it
also immediately vaporizes so it adds to
the big show of this you know part of
what you see is steam you know part of
what you see is smoke so overcoming
those technical difficulties especially
with regards to getting the cameras to
start firing you know the closest any
speck Terrier can be to the launch site
is three miles and I said well how close
do you guys view it from you know I want
to I want to be there I don't want to be
with all the Yahoo's it's the press I
want to be with you guys you know and
they said three miles
like that's how close we get to the
launch and I just thought oh this is
ridiculous but you know in order to
document the thing I wanted to the
cameras had to be very close to the
vehicle so I had a electrical engineer
build me these sound triggers that would
work within the parameters of the
assignment and as soon as the sound from
the engines firing started cameras
started firing so what I had to do is I
had to figure out like what image is I'm
making musters gonna randomly set up a
bunch of cameras right now I want to
document this thing as a story
so it's storyboard each launch and I'd
figure out what camera where it would be
placed the focal length place would be
number the camera and I laid out all the
boards before I start setting camera so
I know what the shuttle does
I know what it does it goes up it rolls
it's it's it's very calculated every
time so I know I can compose frames that
are gonna yield images that are strong I
just don't want to be repeating myself
so this is the press site this is the
old launch clock from the Apollo era
kind of a relic of that era and this is
how far away I am from the actual launch
so this right here is the launch tower
and that's here's here's this Bay and
here's our clock and there's the tower
and literally the first time I thought
this is ridiculous look how far away um
this is not gonna be cool it could not
be any further from not cool I
consciously didn't photograph any
landings it was all about this gesture
you know this grand gesture you know to
me a landing was it was almost like
landings are kind of bittersweet you
know you're happy the vehicle returned
with the payload the experience that was
had by all aboard but there's something
about the grandeur that we talked about
earlier that there was so such an
expression of optimism for me so here we
go
it's two minutes into the flight it's 44
miles downrange at the tip of that smoke
column you can just see the engines just
as they're ready to burn out this is
Atlantis I love this angle for the
shuttle I call it her sexy angle I just
I really like that angle for her
till the ice see all the ice falling
down off the tank from the liquid oxygen
liquid hydrogen these are always tricky
to set the frames for because you know
I'll set the frame up the pad and then
just tilt up to the sky and lock the
camera off set the focus and walk away
from it it's very unsettling to look
through a camera lens and all there is a
sky this Atlantis I was also really
fortunate that for the three last
launches I had three different types of
weather so I got some very distinct
looking unique images from each launch
this is one of NASA's helicopters that
they fly around during the launch just
to watch things that's the column that
big long black shadow up on the top
there is the ceiling of the clouds
that's the shadow cast by the column on
the clouds I always loved that
everything's just so big it's audacious
you know I think Charlie Duke of Apollo
he said look I don't even understand how
this thing works
I know my part of it I know my part of
it this is audacious that would even try
this thing but I can tell you what it's
not gonna fail because of me I know how
to do my part of this thing and I love
that I love how optimistic that is you
know it's just this belief it's his
faith that these thousands of people
thousands of people that have been
working on this thing have all put their
piece into it and it's just this there's
such a beauty to it there's a great Neil
Armstrong quote which is a mystery
creates Wonder and wonders man's desire
to understand and I thought this really
uh this really wrapped it up so thanks
very much